what's going on everybody welcome to
part two of sentiment analysis streaming
app with dash and awesomeness tutorial
series in this story what we're doing is
streaming tweets from Twitter into a
database and before we insert into a
database we're calculating the sentiment
and saving that as well with the idea
being we can later do analysis and all
that and visualize it and stuff in - so
to start we have well basically I'm all
everything's can be covered here is
basically stuff that's already been
covered either in this series or in
previous tutorials so again we're not
gonna be really writing anything out
it's just connecting concepts together
so that's really all I'm gonna do so one
is with SQLite just this SQLite series
if you don't know anything about MySQL
SQLite and all that you can check those
out and then the other is streaming
tweets with tweet P which basically just
gonna use this code right here the only
thing I would say and then we're going
to use SQLite not MySQL just simply
because for everyone to follow along
MySQL can be kind of tedious especially
on Windows to set up so SQLite everybody
has it if you've got Python so it's good
to go
now if you don't have twee P pip install
tweet be otherwise this is like a simple
example of how a Twitter stream would
would work and look all you have to do
is fill in your key your secret your
token and your access I can't remember
API secret I can remember what the a
secret is but anyways if you don't have
that what you need to do is you need to
head to apps dot twitter.com you can
just follow that that tutorial down here
again it's linked to in the text-based
tutorial I'll put it links to that in
the description you can check it out but
basically you just got up the account
you'll I think to make any app you have
to have a phone connected to your
Twitter account I can't remember
everything but anyways you'll need these
four things don't worry that's not my
key so anyway and in this case this
would stream things for the term car so
what I could do is I could populate that
and at least show you that running so
let me pause this real quick and let
just run it real quick okay so the
streams look something like this
it's relatively hard to read anything
that's happening let me just cancel the
build but basically it just returns
these massive JSON objects with all
kinds of data 90% of which you probably
don't care at all about but but they
return a bunch of stuff so basically
what we want to do is load in this JSON
parse out things like the tweet maybe
there's other things you might want to
parse out but probably all you're really
interested in is the tweet and in this
case it was all tweets about cars okay
had to remove my keys now the other
thing I had to do too is fix the print
statement apparently that tutorial was
so old it was Python too but it was also
slashed Python 3 because I printed with
parentheses here whatever okay so once
we have that that basically just streams
but again it was streaming a bunch of
stuff not it was streaming everything
that contains the word car or the term
car or the substring is a proper word
probably hear of car now
what we want to do is kind of we want to
both generate sentiment on this and we
want to insert this data into a database
so that database what I can do too is
just kind of copy and paste that in here
we're gonna use SQLite the act of
connecting to a database if it doesn't
exist creates it boom
then we've got a simple create table
this table simple it just has a UNIX a
tweet and sentiment so UNIX obviously is
just unix time from twitter that's in
milliseconds so you'll need to divide by
a thousand or just tell whatever you're
using to convert those to like a date
that it's milliseconds tweet will just
be the tweet itself and then sentiment
is that the value to the sentiment that
we're gonna read in so let me see if I
can't get this one back too
dude text blob I was hoping to do yeah
analysis on polarity cuz that's the one
I want to use I think this time I've
initially built this with Vader
sentiment because it's quicker but now
I'm curious as I record this a test text
blob instead just to see what I what I
think so so that's how you would create
a table and then basically we're just
going to combine everything into here to
create the script that's going to run
through it and actually I think I'll
just copy and paste that one as well and
then talk about the changes so in this
case let me see if that's all so yeah
it's the end so in this case this is
what the one that I built was using
Vader sentiment I'm gonna swap that here
in just a second
otherwise it creates that table if it
doesn't exist it also runs create tables
so it'll make that table if that table
doesn't yet exist and that's about it
and then basically on the listener what
its gonna do is its first of all going
to try and accept here its accepts on
key error because sometimes there is no
tweet which is odd to me so then we're
going to use the JSON library to load in
the string from data text so data is
gonna be basically it's what's passed
its that an entire chunk that entire
JSON so we're gonna load that JSON save
it to data so that's all like a
dictionary object basically it's not
quite I don't think JSON objects in
Python I mean like when you use the JSON
library I don't think that's actually a
dictionary but it's like a dictionary so
anyways we're gonna reference it with
data text then we've got the time we're
gonna grab the time stamp so that's the
time stamp of the tweet and then here
what we're doing is calculating that
sentiment so what I'd like to do is come
into here and actually change this and I
want to change this to be what we used
here so I'm Marie I'm gonna bring in
text blob so from text blob I'm going to
import text blob
and then the sentiment the analysis will
be text blob of the line where are you
so here and so it's not line it's gonna
be tweet and then sentiment is gonna be
analysis dot sentiment dot polarity I
believe analysis sentiment dot polarity
yes
okay so in this case just for the just
so it's clear what we found before was
and what we did and this is not this is
not where we left off with the 100%
accuracy but we found that a large
percentage of things have a zero
sentiment which I think is totally valid
especially for this library so so we
don't need to add any thresholds here
it's only later when we go to actually
do sentiment and say something has a
positive or a negative sentiment I would
just say anything at zero is neutral and
anything truly above zero is positive of
anything below zero so if it equals zero
neutral if it's above zero positive
below zero negative anyway then we
insert into sentiment taking great care
depending on which basically which
database we're using but you always want
to watch out anytime you're allowing
users to create the input a tweet is an
input you want to make sure that you're
using something that's going to sanitize
any of your inputs and this is the
proper methodology for it with SQLite
other than that I think that's basically
everything we want to try and except
here I think I added later down the road
a couple of other things that I think
I'd like to go ahead and just add here
so one thing I know I added was indexes
for our I'm just gonna find it here yeah
and then awhile true for the rest of it
so now that we've kind of run through
everything and I'll talk about why we're
tracking everything let me just do this
again one more time
and I'll try to remember to update this
in the text-based version for this this
toriel basically we're just creating all
of these as an index just to see if it
was would make it quicker I haven't
really decided if it actually helps
there's reason to believe later on down
the road when the things that we're
using we really can't optimize it
anymore
the one reason you wouldn't want to
create indexes that I know of is it's
basically just like a memory hog in this
case I didn't really care I want it to
be as fast as possible so I did create
indexes you can you can decide you're
smarter than me and and do whatever you
want there I don't I won't be offended
the other thing is for random reasons it
was still breaking and I couldn't figure
out why so I just made it a while true
loop any time it breaks will just sleep
for five seconds print out the error
just in case it's something that keeps
hitting otherwise we'll continue trying
if you disconnect and reconnect too many
times to the Twitter API it is going to
throttle you and will not give you
access for you know thirty seconds or
something like that so just be patient
and try again if you hit any of those
codes like if it returns like a 411 or a
you know something like that
just google it Twitter API 411 or
something like that and you can find out
what it means sometimes it's
unauthorized sometimes it's you know
it's all kinds of stuff so anyways keep
that in mind so what I'm going to do is
populate the key secret token and all
that and I'm gonna make sure this
actually runs also it should as it runs
it should output time tweet in the
sentiment so the changes I've made are
not here darn it okay let's just make
that change one more time I'm glad I
caught that so analysis equals text blob
of the tweet and then sentiment is
analysis dot sentiment dot polarity and
then rather than Vater sentiment
it's from text text blob import text
blob that should be it
let me populate the keys and all that
okay and uh let me run it let's see what
happens
hopefully not an error looks like an
error what you got for me
oh no module name you need to code
that's a good thing that I hid that
because I never talked about it
so especially for stuffing it in tube we
just want to get rid of all those fancy
characters so on Twitter you can make
all kinds of cute smiley faces and stuff
we want to just simplify this quite a
bit so I'm going to use unit of code to
do it we might not actually need to I'm
tempted to not do it but I'm gonna go
ahead and leave that there it's just a
pip install you need to code and I'm
gonna go ahead and do that real quick
okay got you need the code and let's try
that one more time still errors what are
we hitting now
oh we've defined that analyzer from
Vader sentiment still and again alright
here we go and we're off
so for some reason this is normal from
Twitter it's just like a bunch of stuff
pause a bunch of stuff pause I don't
know why that's happening years ago when
I used the Twitter streaming API it
streamed constantly it would max out
anything on any network I threw at it
and that's and it's only the free
version is only one percent of the
firehose so I'm not sure if if now my
Internet's too fast and that's why it's
it's it pauses because before it was
just a constant stream but anyways it
does that so anyway okay so now we
should be building this database there
she is right there
growing hopefully pretty quickly sure
enough it is and and yeah so what I'm
gonna go ahead and do is let this
database kind of populate for a while
and and then once it's substantially
sized I'll pick up on the next next
tutorial and honestly it'll probably be
decent there's at least probably a few
popular words that we could use right
now and it would actually be okay so
actually I probably I'll just continue
straight into the next one okay so at
this point we've got everything coming
in I'll just go ahead and why would
can't I think if I just scroll up it
yeah so here's our time this is the
actual tweet and then as we can see
here's the polarity and sure enough I
mean since we're using text blog we can
see it clear as day there are a lot of
0.0 in here I mean there's a lot of non
zero point zero so and not advertiser
friendly word anyway yeah we've got a
lot of a lot of zeros that'll be
interesting I'm interested to see I'm
gonna compare this one to Vador
sentiment yeah why there's so many
easier well this one's just hard first
of all I don't think this is English a
lot of these aren't English maybe that's
the problem we've got many not wow
that's a lot of non
English tweets going on look at all
these routes Allah it looks like Spanish
huh interesting anyway we'll see cuz
I'll be able to compare the two okay so
that's all for now questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise in the next
tutorial we'll be reading from here and
at least beginning to graph this stuff
in - rather than looking at it in a
console so that's what you guys have to
look forward to see in the next video